GIACOMMO BIGGIERO: --transit
agencies across the world.
So what I'm going to
talk to you about today
is how we've gathered
customer insight and data
to build business cases and to
subsequently grow our company.
This might be a little
different to some
of the other presentations
insofar as some of the data
that we've been collecting
isn't just from analytics
but is from social behavior
and beyond, really.
So a little bit
of flash history.
We started writing
mobile apps back in 2002
when phones looked like that.
That was off the
back of the promise
that this was very imminently
going to become a huge channel.
Of course, that didn't
really materialize
for quite a number of years,
which meant for the first years
we were really quite
basically poor, I guess.
But it did give us a
lot of time to think
about the sort of reach
that mobile apps could
deliver once the
market was ready.
And it was an opportunity really
to think about doing something
really exciting, something
really interesting,
that could touch the lives of
so many different people in one
go-- through one medium.
So how do we leverage
that kind of volume?
So what kind of insight,
what kind of goals
did we set ourselves
at that time.
So I guess there's no real
answer to how you leverage
large volumes in a
commercially viable way.
But we set ourselves
a few rules.
A few ideas.
We thought that the apps
had to be really compelling.
And in order to be
really compelling,
they had to be free and
available for everyone.
We thought that in order
to leverage the scale
to its maximum, we would
have to have a model that
was transactional to generate
the recurring revenue.
And we wanted to focus
on those environments
where mobile could become the
ubiquitous way of doing things.
So how do we make it happen?
So our ethos has
been really to focus
on trying to solve
real world problems.
Trying to build business
cases around solving pain
points that people go
through every single day.
Sort of trying to focus
more on what people need
rather than what they want.
So we started focusing
on the transit agency
because of the very
large-- I've disappeared.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You focus
on the transit agencies.
GIACOMMO BIGGIERO: So I
focused on the-- we focused
on the transits agencies--
transit industry--
because the volumes
were so large
and because the customer
experience is really
quite clunky.
And basically it's
ripe for innovation.
So the first thing we looked
at was the airline industry,
which was the first mover to
move to digital ticketing.
And that completely disrupted
travel agencies, et cetera.
And everybody started
buying their tickets online.
And I guess it's interesting
because with airline, people
have quite a big
financial commitment when
they buy a ticket.
They're sort of planning
things in advance
with their friends or
family at destination.
That takes some time.
Plus the tickets
are yield managed,
which means the
further in advance
you buy the ticket, the
cheaper it's going to be.
So the likelihood, really, is
that users are going to be--
or prospective
ticket buyers-- are
going to be buying these tickets
at home, sat at their table,
on a website, way before
they're going to travel.
So we looked at other
areas of transit
where mobile could
be more effective.
And that's when we
started to investigate
the data around railway and bus.
Railway was
particularly interesting
because everyone was buying
tickets at the station.
This wasn't for any kind of
lack of websites or ability
to buy tickets in advance.
That's just what
people were doing.
They were just walking up at
the stations and buying tickets.
They were craving for a
last minute experience.
Perhaps, it's because it's a
smaller financial commitment,
they're going somewhere
for the weekend,
they're seeing their
folks, whatever.
It's a much simpler kind of
experience that they're after.
So in the UK we saw
that 70% of tickets
were bought at the station.
But this experience is quite
a painful one in practice.
So for those of you that
have lived in the UK,
in London, or in any large
city for that matter,
you'll see that
congestion and ticket
queues are really,
really painful.
And that's only really
going to get worse
off the back of urbanization,
population growth.
We're only going to see more
and more people rocking up
at stations trying
to buy tickets.
And the government's
very keen to make
sure the congestion
in the stations
is limited and mitigated
as much as possible.
And the transit
agencies obviously
need to bear the cost of
all those ticket vending
machines and all that
equipment, maintenance,
and overhead associated with
cash handling, et cetera.
So we gathered a lot
of data and looked
at how this market was working.
And there was quite a
big pain point here.
Not just for the consumer that
wanted something last minute,
on the go and
instead have to queue
up in this horrible
experience, but also
for the operator that was
spending a lot of money
in trying to sell these
tickets and giving up
a lot of valuable retail
space such as this image
shows in Gatwick Airport which
could be filled with shops
or a pub which is going
to generate revenue
for the operator and is going
to be a much more exciting user
experience, I think,
than queuing up.
So with that insight from the
user-- from the passenger--
kind of data that we
gathered and the insight
from the operators'
commercial drivers,
we came up with the
idea of transforming
the phone into the
ticket vending machine
and transforming the phone
into the ticket itself.
That way we could deliver
some of that last minute,
on the go user experience that
the passengers are looking for
and that marries itself
so well with mobile,
and at the same time drive down
the costs for the agencies that
are trying to sell
these tickets.
So that way we saw not only the
adoption from the user's case,
but also an industry
that's willing to back
this new technology.
So that means no
ticket queues, no more
need to scale your ticket
vending machines as previously
planned.
If you have a new channel
you can sell tickets through,
it doesn't cost you
anything as an operator
because you as a consumer
are bringing your own ticket
vending machine.
And in this picture
alone we can see
about a quarter of
a million dollars
worth of ticket vending machine.
And if we think that that
can service about four
to five people at
once, how much does
it cost to service
100 people that
have got mobile
phones-- nothing.
So the drivers there
are really obvious
and the operator can replace
these ticket vending machines
with any other
retailing activity
that would actually generate
direct revenue for them.
So we did a lot of research
around the technology of ticket
vending machines and
what we were working with
to understand what
the price points were
to enable us to come up with
a commercial model that would
allow us to leverage the huge
volumes that mobile brings.
And cash handling
turns out to be
an extremely expensive affair.
And a lot of transit
agencies such as Transport
For London are actually
getting rid of cash
altogether, replacing it with
contactless EMV or Oyster card
or other technologies.
So mobile is an
ideal channel for us
to look at to exploit that
volume because you are taking
all the boxes for the operator
as well as the passenger.
So that was kind of what we
built our initial business
case off of.
But I guess gathering
insight, executing on it,
growing off the back of
that is a continuous process
that we are going
through as a business.
And it's something that you
have to go through continuously
if you want to continue to
grow and fulfill your business
model.
So once that business
model is in place
there are still more
things to learn.
There's still more
data to gather.
And there's still more things
to action off the back of that.
So we developed our
own analytics package
that leverages some of
the existing tools, Google
Analytics, and a lot of
other things out there
and aggregates them together to
display something which really
gives us a lot of information
about passenger transit.
How are they using
those tickets?
How are they traveling?
When are they traveling?
When are they buying?
How can we start designing our
new features or our new updates
to really maximize
the user experience?
So there's a lot of work
that's gone into that.
But perhaps the most
interesting part
has really been
gathering the insight
from the industry itself.
So in the UK, for
example, there's
a highly fragmented rail market.
There's a lot of
private operators.
And in order for mobile to be
the ubiquitous way of buying
tickets, we need to make sure
that those tickets are accepted
and validated by all the
operators in the market.
So some operators might
accept it and others
might not because they need to
be validated in a specific way.
So in order to
accelerate our growth,
we kind of collected
all the information
and established relationships
with the operators
and decided to develop
another suite of mobile apps
that conductors could use
to validate those tickets.
So the conductor would
come along with their app
and exploiting the onboard
camera on the device,
take a picture of the bar
code or read the NFC tag
and validate the
ticket that way.
Again, without the
need for the operator
to invest in further
infrastructure
to enable mobile ticketing.
So it's again, leveraging
existing hardware.
Users bring their own hardware.
Conductors bring
their own hardware.
There's no additional
investment.
And that way we can
accelerate the adoption
of mobile ticketing.
And what we learned from that
was that adoption is growing
but not at the pace
that we wanted to.
So we started looking at a
new model for our business.
We started looking
at other environments
where there was only
a single operator.
So there wasn't this
need for interoperation.
So people could have a
very simple proposition--
mobile ticketing
wherever you travel.
You don't have to specifically
go on one operator or another
to use it.
And so we developed
our JustRide product,
which is not only applicable
to large transit areas
but also can work across
different modes of transit.
So this is a product
now we've launched
in markets outside the UK.
It's live in Boston,
in San Diego.
It also works in
non-rail environments.
We recently landed a
contract with Thames Clippers
to do the boats on
the Thames as well.
So learning from that
experience in the UK
has really allowed us to
design a product that's
much more flexible.
So currently we have 18 agencies
and clients across the world.
We currently service about 65%
of the UK market by operator.
We have quite a few millions
of downloads and lots
and lots of requests
for per minute.
And it's been really quite
exciting journey from us.
And as of yesterday, we are
very excited to announce
that we landed a contract
to do mobile ticketing
for the Metropolitan Transit
Authority in New York.
So that's a really exciting
turning point for us.
So, yeah.
That's kind of Masabi's
journey and how
we've use the insight
of how an industry works
and how passenger behavior
is to leverage the scale
that mobile ticketing
can deliver.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GIACOMMO BIGGIERO: Wow.
That was really quick.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
now we'll have que--